roger is with us in Little Rock hi Roger
how are you hey Dave I'm better than I
deserve - how can I help
well um so I'm at the point where my car
needs to be replaced and I knew this was
going to be happening to happen just
with the repair record and everything in
the age of the car I've been saving for
a little over a year for this great but
the but the car you know just need to
replace now I've got the cash to pay for
something that's in the five six
thousand dollar range mm-hmm I'm getting
a lot of pressure from family to buy
something that's more reliable in the
$12,000 range for the payment plan and
you know I've listened to this show
enough to know it's not a great idea
how do I kind of have those
conversations with family while
respecting you know their wisdom but
also you know sticking to what I've
chosen to do how old are they my parents
in their mid fifties hold are you I'm 25
okay well I've got a 25 year old son and
I
it's a boundary violation for me to
start telling him how to spend his money
when he didn't ask now if you ask you're
asking for it if your dad what's your
opinion you know then you're out then
you're going to get my opinion but um
you know just say dad I appreciate you
know appreciate what your thoughts are
on that but I have a goal to be
debt-free and in order to be debt-free I
can't take on the car payment and that
means a lot to me it's a big goal of
mine and not going to drive a $5,000 car
for very long but if I get a car payment
I'm going to be you know worth nothing
and I don't want an order payment I'm
not ever going to have a car payment
again so just um you know and if he has
to if he if he or she feels like they
have to interfere past that then they
have boundary issues I mean if you if
you just respectfully look at them and
go hey thank you for your opinion I
appreciate that but I got this huge goal
of being debt-free and you know that's
um that you know therefore I can't go
into debt so I'm I'm going to buy this
$5,000 car and all upgrade in a few
years when I've got you know the cash to
do that and I'll have the cash to do
that because I'll be debt-free at that
point
and you know if you can make it can't
make a simple statement like that and
then they don't but out then you've got
some issues with them yeah and I think
they're I think a lot of their reasoning
is well if you pay for something in the
twelve thousand dollar range it's going
to be more reliable that taking a chance
on something that's five thousand or so
yeah and if you if you bought something
in the thirty thousand dollar range of
being more reliable than the twelve
thousand that doesn't mean it's smart
care you know if you buy a million
dollar house it's nicer than a hundred
thousand dollar house - all the time
just about I mean almost every time it's
nice and you know so that reasoning
stands true but that's not enough reason
to go into death and so if you're asking
me if you should do that which it sounds
like you're trying to hide that question
in there no pay cash dude don't go back
in the car payment land our movement
land stupid hey guys thanks for watching
if you enjoyed this video click the
subscribe button to get the latest
content and check out these other great
clips from the show
[Music]